MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome
back to 8.701.
We continue discussion
of nuclear decays
with gamma decays.
We have seen that we can
understand nuclear stability
or instability.
We discussed alpha
decays and beta decays.
Now after the discussion
of the shell model,
it is apparent that transition
from various nuclear states
can be accomplished via the
admission of a photon, a gamma
ray.
Gamma decays are specifically
important in decay chains
following an alpha
decay or a beta decay
where the remnant,
the daughter nuclei,
is left over in
an excited state.
Then the de-excitation follows
with the admission of a photon.
Practical consequences
of this alpha example--
in fission processes where a
significant amount of energies
can be released with
photons, radiotherapy
where we try to
remove cancer cells
or kill cancer cells
with gamma rays.
Medical imaging works this way.
And in general, you can use
the emission of those photons
to deduce the spin and the
parity of excited states.
If you go back very
early to this lecture,
we discussed the Wu experiment.
And also there we
used gamma rays
in order to reduce the spin
and the parity of the states
involved.
So nuclear spectroscopy, we
haven't discussed the detectors
yet.
But what's shown
here in this picture
are two characteristic
gamma ray spectra
from the case of
cobalt and cesium.
And if you just focus on
the blue line, for example,
you see here this peak.
This corresponds to the
energy of a transition.
But then photons,
when they're emitted,
they can go through
Compton scattering.
And they can lose
through Compton
scattering some of the energy.
So you see this tail here.
And then in this tail
you see additional peaks.
And those additional peaks
can come from the fact
that a photon can produce
an electron-positron pair.
And then you see one
or two of those pairs
in cases where one electron
or positron, or both of them,
have escaped the detection.
So whenever you look
at a nuclear decay,
you find spectrums of the sort.
And then there are various
Compton scattering--
depends obviously
on the material
around and the
composition and also
this single and double
escape kind of peaks,
quite characteristic for the
material you're looking at.
So from this, on
nuclear spectroscopy
you can learn about the sample
composition, the element
composition of the probe.
And interesting effect
is the Mössbauer effect.
Here again, I'll
try to remind you
of the discussion of
special relativity.
We looked at the energy of an
emitted and an absorbed photon.
And because in this emission
process the leftover nuclei,
there has to be a
momentum balance.
So there is a recoil
on the leftover nuclei.
So that means it starts moving.
And because it's moving, we
have to do a Doppler correction
of the energy, meaning that the
emitted photon energy is not
equal to the energy
needed in order to excite
the nuclear state again.
So this leads then to
those energy spectrum.
Here, they're the
natural widths.
And only in this overlapping
region here you can reabsorb.
Now the most Mössbauer effect
now is a special variation
of what I just described.
In cases where the nucleon
is part of a lattice,
the lattice can absorb
the recoiling energy.
And it leads like to a situation
of very, very heavy objects
absorbing this recoil.
And in those cases, you can
have resonant effects, meaning
that this emission line,
then absorption lines,
they lay over each
other quite strongly.